yeah it reminds you of what is real like
and what is not real the online world is
really in some ways like the chattering
of demons like let's say Tanner these an
anonymous troll type people you know you
also know that the not all of them but a
lot of people that's not their whole
personality anyways it's almost like I'm
gonna go online and I can play this like
role uh you know and then they go back
and they they like live their life it's
almost like a little like a little it's
a video game it's a first person shooter
video game right I'm going online I'm
gonna own the labs I'm going online I'm
gonna dismantle Mega people yeah and
that's my way I'm virtuous I'm playing a
game and I'm virtualized while I'm doing
it
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
thank you
so hello everyone I am here again with
Greg hurwitz those of you that follow my
channel will have seen him on my channel
he is a best-selling author he's written
orphanax and several other series
including Batman of which I'm a big fan
um but he was also part of The Exodus
group that met to talk about Exodus for
like 32 hours
uh and the the videos of Exodus have
been doing it's crazy the first episode
is more than two million views on
YouTube and they've also had you know
similar types of success on the uh daily
wear our daily wire platform and so I
thought it'd be great with Greg to talk
about our experience there you know kind
of where it led him and his thought and
in my thinking and uh and hopefully yeah
start from there so maybe Greg if you
want to start us off you were in some
ways the
you were like the the strangest
character in the group in the sense
from like you know you came from a more
secular world you know you're you're
writing novels you're more uh you're not
like someone who would spend that much
time in the Bible in your life and so
for you it was like a discoveries I'd
like to know a little bit what your
experience was in in talking about this
with us
um I mean the first thing that I thought
about that you know as you know I moved
between a lot of different communities
and groups and it's one of the great
things for me about being a novelist is
I get to just explore I'm fascinated by
how people think
um I'm I'm nearly impossible to offend I
don't share a lot of the kind of hard
partisan ideological lines and have lots
of different discussions I mean the
first thing that struck me was you know
just it was really an honor to be around
a table with that many people who have
that level of expertise in something
it's really it was humbling
um it's really interesting it's my
favorite form of Engagement I like doing
things from time to time where I'm the
kind of neophyte or the one who's who
isn't the expert right so there's
certain areas and perspectives I had
talking about narrative I have you know
I have read the Bible I have taken
courses but like you you put me next to
you or uh you know Prager or James Orr
or Oz Guinness and you know it's like a
it's like a third grader playing
basketball with Michael Jordan
um now that said you know
one of the things that's amazing when
talking about something is as you know
epic and essential and enduring as
Exodus is it's like every view is
welcome and value too right so it's not
like there was a a bar that we were
having conversations about historical
references we're finding a way in
towards meaning and I thought that
everybody was very uh welcoming towards
me and it's what a great way to
to engage with everybody's best part in
a way you know it's funny it was it was
a different deal for me probably than
anybody else who was in that
seminar in that there's certain people
from certain communities who I'm from
who have very strong opinions about
other members of the group in certain
Arenas particularly when it gets in a
partisanship but it's like you know
that's also part of the problem is that
we've made
Politics the sort of Apex thing that
shines the light on top of everything
and the whole point of having community
and having intellectual discussions and
having Fellowship is that you meet
people around common ground and
territory right where they have Grace
and wisdom and generosity and I thought
that was very much on display yeah
um but you know in terms of how it
changed my thinking it was pretty
revolutionary for me
on a bunch of fronts
yeah I know that one of the things that
you brought up in in the during the
seminar but also doing conversation was
this Vision in Exodus that they have
about the relationship between the
center and the margin between kind of
identity and The Fringe so maybe you can
tell us a little bit about what
let's say how that how that surprised
you or how that affected your thinking
in terms of what's in the Bible
well there's a line in it I forget where
we were talking about The Fringe and one
of the things is is
I like The Fringe being The Fringe you
know and we were saying I was saying you
know we were talking about this with
like gender and presentation and artists
and I think there's one point where I
said look having one Prince the artist
the artist formerly known as Prince is
amazing if you walk in and there's 50
you kind of don't know what to do with
yourself you know so it's sort of this
interesting notion that that in a lot of
ways I think maybe maybe certain secular
thinkers have this notion that when
people talk about the center of the
center holding it's to the exclusion of
The Fringe but I think that in part that
actually can be a relationship if The
Fringe in the center are arranged
properly that nourishes and protects and
holds The Fringe in its meaningful place
right whatever The Fringe is I'm not I'm
not labeling that specifically but you
know my understanding like from where I
come from my personal beliefs the fact
that I'm a writer
um based on my you know what what are
the things Big Five personality traits
right I'm super high in openness like I
have I have traits that map onto a more
liberal world view you and I've talked
about at length the necessity for both
liberal and conservative thinking to
navigate complex change right the
Liberals are the breaks and the Liberals
are the gas and the conservatives or the
breaks and if you stop on the brakes you
don't go anywhere and if you step on the
gas you go off a cliff or run into a
wall and so the negotiation between
those sides is essential
um but you know I had this sort of
Reawakening that
I really like
The Fringe being The Fringe when I'm
visiting It On The Fringe to have a more
open liberal uh artistic Community or
sub-community right and even I grew up
south of you know in the San Francisco
Bay Area a lot of the politics in that
region are gonna be more liberal some of
them now tend left in a way that I'm not
a particular fan of I'm much more of a
liberal than I am a lefty I mean I'm not
a lefty at all but also this awareness
that like that's a beautiful thing about
San Francisco but it should be San
Francisco it shouldn't also be Iowa and
the whole Midwest and the South
and Oz said something and we talked a
little bit about Miriam I think we might
have discussed this previously but you
know two things that really struck me
was you know Miriam coming in and having
her sort of excessively pure remark when
Moses wanted to have uh uh Ethiopian
wife and then you know the the joke of
God coming down and turning her like you
know a leprosy Snow White and she had to
be excluded from the camp before allowed
back in you know the warnings against
excessive Purity which makes the center
uh unwelcoming right and
um ossified
um and so it was very interesting for me
how that was like built in with a ton of
Terror and consideration you know
likewise the fact that
um you know
um Caleb and it's Jacob yeah were the
only one Center the promises and Caleb
Joshua I mean yeah
and that Caleb was from the mixed
multitude right he was not necessarily
like you know that that that that these
different different people Outsiders
were welcomed in and integrated in
certain ways but there's also certain
um
rules and structures that have to be in
place in order to accommodate that so
for me it was very eye-opening to see
the sort of
um
care and thought morally and
strategically and spiritually and
psychologically and lovingly about how
these different parts play and you told
the story which I I don't want to share
it was a personal story about in the
church and how you've managed to have
certain members who felt more Fringe
almost literally in terms of where they
positioned in the church and how the
church welcomed them so that part was
key and the other the other thing for me
ozgin has had a remark to me at one
point and it was it was this funny
moment sometimes you have a remark where
you feel like you cross a threshold and
do a different understanding
um and it's something that's really
obvious but you know one of the things
he was talking about when we talked
about globalism you know I come from a
perspective a more liberal perspective
of like globalism is great right it's we
have better trade we have cheaper Goods
we've lifted half the world out of
poverty right there's all this
positivity and Oz just in a in a private
conversation with me just had this
little reframing to be like but imagine
a global morality that goes away that
right where everybody it's some at some
higher level determines what's better
down to the locality right of every
different choice and what a horrifying
Vision that is right that's like a a
vision of
such an authoritarian the amount of
force and bureaucratic might and
authoritarian might to lock that into
place like in a China let's say yeah and
in combination with the conversation we
had about Exodus about the distribution
of power across and vertically it just
really struck me and then I started to
think about everything in that regard to
it kind of cracked open for me an
understanding of some of the criticisms
of you know Carbon edicts handed down
from Brussels that need to pertain to
Canadian Farmers right or Notions of
trans rights that get farmed out through
social media so that a you know a a
community with no elective body and no
spokespeople all of a sudden they're
gonna have a mob mentality or online mob
made up of people that nobody even knows
who they are half of them could be
foreign players right from a St
Petersburg troll Farm screaming about
how values have to be affected in every
sort of community all at once
um and then also just about the
efficiency of moving resources up and
down and the more that they're moved up
at a higher level there's more sort of
codified corruption and rotten the
system which I'd understood already a
good amount but just thinking more and
more about the necessity for for local
kind of governance and value setting
once a baseline has been established
there's Baseline American values right
around dignity and freedom
um but to allow variants within the sub
communities because there's no other way
to do it and for a long time I've been
thinking about you know America right
now is in a standoff and what is not
going to happen is that one side
prevails and dominates and rules over
the other side that's not going to be an
outcome that is a world anyone wants to
live in there's got to be some sort of
partnership and there has to be a return
to Value sets and relationships that are
differentiated at a local level
um so I've been thinking really
differently since those conversations
and then also starting to understand
much more you know Dennis talked about
you know one of the beautiful things in
Exodus is it's the law but it's wrapped
in the sacred right and if you don't
have the wrapping of law in something
transcendent
right then it will become overgrown in
cancerous and turn into
HR departments or endless countless
regulations right or like you know
endless
School administrator bureaucratic States
within educational environments where
they start to eat the primary point of
Education yeah um so I've been chewing
on a lot of this and it's been altering
a lot my thinking about how to balance
and integrate the best of what
liberalism needs to offer which is sort
of watering and nourishing the culture
with new ideas and people so it doesn't
stagnate and the essential nature of how
you hold Center yeah
no I think that's that's great and I and
I think that that also in some ways I
think was the most striking thing for me
during The Exodus seminar that that was
able to come out
that that structure like that kind of
subsidiary structure where
you know even the 12 tribes exist
independently right they all have their
own identity but they nonetheless you
know all look towards the Tabernacle
they all worship the same God and that
and they have some aspects like Moses
and Aaron and the Priestly cast that act
as an overarching structure uh
interestingly enough in in Exodus that
overarching structure like the Priestly
cast they don't have land
and so there's like this trade-off
situation where you don't want to have
them
have land and have power but then also
be an overarching structure on others
like you kind of say okay you'll have
this but you take this there's this very
beautiful way in which
they're able to to have something which
which is over all of them but then
remain keeping their crunchy you know uh
their crunchy characteristics you know
and that that is that's been even with
Arc like people were talking about Arc
and you're going to be there as well in
Arc that's one of the things that we're
trying to help people see is this need
to to understand identity that way right
identity as
layers of participation and not just the
state and the individual the way that we
kind of tend to look at it in the modern
world and I think your image of America
in some ways that is the best vision of
what America could be which is a kind of
decentralized cultures that that coexist
that recognize each other's value and
that understand that also that they
don't necessarily agree with each other
and all the way in all their alignment
but have enough in common so that they
they can exist together uh and nor
should they and nor is that the goal the
goal is not that we all agree that is
not an American goal and that's not
what's best for America yeah yeah and so
I yeah I I really that was really for me
one of the biggest the biggest takeaways
from Exodus 2 is is that that Vision
came out so clearly and even rereading
the text you know sometimes you know I'd
read it I reread it occasionally but
rereading it for that seminar and then
in the discussion I was like wow there's
more about this Then I then I even
thought like there's just more of this
this there's even this idea in some ways
that
gets taken up and in some ways that gets
taken back up in Jesus in the New
Testament which is that
it's as if all the laws
have to be contained in their allegiance
to God and Jesus says right love your
God and love your neighbor it's like
that's what the law is for if you don't
have that then the all these regulations
and laws you could keep making them more
and more explicit and that's what
happens right if we lose trust within
each other then we the more as the more
Society lose normal trust between people
the longer our contracts become right
and the more like subheadings and like
this and that because yeah account for
every single possible Behavior whereas
before let's say or or in a family or in
a relationship of trust like the
handshake
it's like that's what it's based in like
there's an implicit laws are there but
we don't have to spell them out because
we know that we act in trust and in love
towards each other
one of the things I that's that's
yes that's beautifully stated you know
one of the things I was thinking a lot
about for me having come up you know in
in a secular world but that said my
parents sent me to Jesuit High School
you know I had very I great
relationships with Jesuit priests in
high school we start we read this the
first time I read the Old Testament I
was in bar mitzvotments but nor were my
parents nor were my grandparents I mean
so I'm from a long line of sort of more
secular Jews but really you know a lot
of my the Embrace and attention that's
been paid on the Old Testament and my
identity has been from non-jews it was
Jesuits the first year we read the Old
Testament you know I have a lot of
friends who were uh you know long-time
friends who are Christian who are very
interested in that you know this Exodus
summer I was invited in but I mean I
knew you Jordan and Blackwell were were
my three people I knew I wasn't invited
in by
um you know Prager and Shapiro so it's
this really funny thing that a lot of
the sourcing of my Identity or
connecting with that all the way back to
high school was from Christians you know
so that's it's also is an interesting
point but one of the things I was
thinking about a little bit since then
is
as we're discussing all these primary
values is that for me growing up I had
this amazing
Ben made it Ben made a comment that kind
of blew my mind
um
he had two comments that were that kind
of blew my mind but one of them was he
said something in uh the sort of
critical fast Talking Ben you know
machine gun fire voice but he said look
a lot of these institutions are going on
the fume are on the are on the fumes of
the value sets and structures that they
had in place from let's just say some
religious Foundation I forgot what his
exact phrasing was but I was thinking
about that I was thinking about when I
went through and I had the benefit of
going through some really fine schools
like this Jesuit High School colleges
where the structures were very very
intact it didn't feel there was ideology
creeping in at the edges but it was not
predominant but a lot of what I felt was
holy was were the poets right where it
was Beethoven it was Mozart it was
Shakespeare it was you know
um Plato for me it was a lot of the like
the the
um The Poets uh you know Byron Keats and
Shelley
and so I was constantly reading and
engaging with this stuff that felt like
it was sacred
um and in a way as I was reflecting on
our conversation one of the things that
that of course it's it's
spectacularly obvious to you but less so
for me is that when you're having a
discussion that's specifically about the
Bible what we're talking about is the
thing itself you're talking about here
are the Seven Virtues right here's the
seven deadly sins and it's not proxy by
a poem or by something else or by a play
or for me reading Shakespeare for me
hearing Schumann right or hearing
Beethoven's Ninth
and there's something that's very
interesting in the space between it
because
I think in a lot of my upbringing I
would see that sort of the Sacred light
Shone through let's say the genius of
creation or a brilliant thinker right
even if it's a scientific thinker you
know my proclivity was more towards the
Arts and towards Opera but you know pick
your Genius pick your physicist you know
ramanujin like where you see people are
connected with an order that is greater
than them but it's interesting because
in a way even if you're offset just that
much of admiring the people in the works
that are a reflection of the primary
values there is a tendency to move
towards well do we value hard work do we
value Brilliance do we value the beauty
primarily rather than always knowing
that there's the foundational core value
of you know like what does true humility
really mean it's not like fiend humility
and so I started to read C.S Lewis
um
more C.S Lewis and what's so interesting
is he has a remark in
um shoot I forget where I think it's in
the screw tape letters where he says
that that the sort of aim of of of true
humility is not claiming you don't have
the skills that you want or like fishing
for compliments but if you're an
architect and you build the most
beautiful structure in the world and you
glory in that structure but you're just
as happy
in it existing if you creating it as if
somebody else created it and it just
existed it's like it's such an
interesting way of looking at it as
opposed to me I was coming up with sort
of like the cult of Frank Lloyd Wright I
mean he was so bombastic and Brilliant
and my favorite stories with him are
like you know when if somebody had one
of his houses and they put up a fence
he'd get mad years later and just send a
bulldozer to knock off the feds because
he still considered his house so he's in
court all the time and one time he was
you know they asked him he was on the
stand and they said are you the greatest
architect who ever lived and he said yes
I am and he was walking out it was like
a courthouse scrum and I think his
second wife was Mexican she said Frank
deer did you really did you really have
to say that he said I did dear I was
under oath
[Laughter]
hilarious
you know so it's like but the studying
of of this
is is for me of architecture I thought
of it more through the Brilliance of
what he accomplished and the dance
between space and psychology and having
that it's such a simple notion with C.S
Lewis of like you know enjoy and embrace
your uniqueness and whatever gifts
you're blessed with right don't issue
them with false shows of humility but
the humility is your appreciation that
it can even exist and that you're there
to observe that and so that that staking
of primary values I've been trying to
think about that comment that Ben made
about how some of these secular
societies are on the fumes so you get
past let's say my dad's generation and
he didn't fight in World War II right
they're a generation past a shared
nationally shared crisis where everybody
suffered and learned equally that
doesn't happen in America since World
War II so you have one generation I'm in
the Next Generation but by the time it
comes to our kids it's almost like that
gap between the core values and the
Geniuses and implementers and innovators
it sort of widens in your understanding
of how to bring them together without a
foundational
education let's say whatever that means
whether that's formal or not that brings
together
intellectual Venture and artistic
Venture where the spiritual Foundation
right that's you know greek latin the
biblical text you know different holy
and sacred texts
and then also what these fields of
endeavor are and then the integration of
the two and how they're foundationally
tied to the real world and that's
another essential thing as opposed to
just sort of floating unattached up here
to be like oh well I've published 18
different scholarly articles on you know
you know the jungian Shadow and
Shakespearean tragedy
and it's not fully connected and
integrated all the way and the process
of education is trying to get all of
those pieces together and if you have
them I think you build obviously
stronger relationships stronger sub
communities and you have yourself
organized with the communities across
time with different codes and values and
communities up and down Mount Sinai and
I love that that Exodus you know is so
unabashed the Jews are always so unabash
it and also showing the reality of like
you know Moses is like I'm gonna be
right back I'm just gonna go talk to God
like Aaron just don't do anything dumb
okay I'll be back in like just give me
like a day and I'll come back and it'd
be really good if there wasn't like a
golden calf and a bunch of orgies so
just you know hold the tent so it's very
open-eyed about the fact that there's
all sorts of problems but if that's the
structure that you're constantly and
perfectly navigating up and down you can
imperfectly and humanly move forward in
a structure that works that is that's
reconstituting itself from tyranny and
that little Loop of fleeing tyranny into
the disintegrated unknown of the desert
and then reorienting in a way that's
embodied and solid to move forward
towards the promised land that we won't
reach in our own time or way it's this
mini cycle right it's everything with
psychology I'm going to give up the
tyranny of you know my victimhood about
something I'm gonna give up the tyranny
of thinking that I have to rely on
alcohol I'm going to give up the tyranny
of an abuse story that is keeping me in
a way where I'm powerless and anytime
you give up tyranny obvious or not
obvious
you know what comes isn't joy in The
Liberation but the dizzying terror
freedom of like
now it's me it's it's me and God I hope
and a new understanding and who where
are my people how do I do this yeah yeah
and so that that Loop is like it's it's
fractal like everything we talk about
you know it can be a choice you make it
can be an emotional state it can be the
orientation of your whole life but the
need to build these things solidly that
all the pieces hold together is pretty
staggering in some ways one of the
things that also in The Exodus seminar
that came out for me that I'm surprised
it came out so strong but to me it was
important because it's something that I
been trying to help people understand
it's is that in Exodus there's a sense
in which the center is worship like
and that that it's hard for secular
people and that's how that's why I'm
asking it's hard for sake of the people
because it's like oh man that's a tough
one right that's a that's a tough uh
level but it seems like in Exodus you
can understand it it's that you have to
keep your most precious and highest
attention to the highest thing and it's
like if you if you so if you give your
praise and attention because you're
gonna do it anyways right you're going
to worship all kinds of things you're
gonna you're gonna celebrate all kinds
of things but if you celebrate the
highest and it's not just like a mental
exercise at least in Exodus it's like
you have to do it you have to get
together you know there's things you do
you you kill animals we don't do that
anymore but like you sacrifice things
you sing songs you do all this stuff
um and so and so I'm wondering how that
if that has
mess with you or how would you how do
you see that for for yourself like that
that that part of Exodus kind of came
out like you have to you have to in
someone you have to pray you have to
worship you have to you have to give up
pray to the highest
oh it's it's it's
it's it's been it's been quite intense
man I mean I have my own rituals that
like you know
Jordan and you and anyone could rightly
make fun of me you know from being a
fruity Californian you know it's like
you know so it's like I do I do this
meditative yoga at 115 degrees often
right and one of the things I learned
when I go there that's one of the ways
that I'm the most I feel the most
connected I try and do it every night
when I'm in town I do it sometimes
during the day but it's a it's you know
one of the things that I've discovered
and we talked about this a little bit is
that some of the poses that you have
right A lot of them are like heart
opening but they're positions that are
not dissimilar from prayer positions
that you're taking and I've thought a
lot about how the physiology within our
body you know if you stand in the Rocky
pose your self-esteem actually Rises
right like there's different poses we
have I mean that's Jordan's you know
Infamous essay on the infamous and
famous essay on the lobster right about
but it's so interesting for me moving
through this which is a you know a
different ancient tradition but a lot of
the postures are like you know
prostrating yourself for
prayer like that's what they look like
and you hold it in heat right for you
know in 115 degrees sometimes for five
minutes and you're and
the necessity of ritual
has always been essential to me right I
don't just write when I feel like
writing I don't just sort of exercise
when I feel like it or you know I've had
a lot of different
um skills or disciplines that have
required ritualizing them right what you
have to do with writing what you have to
do with carving is just decide that it's
sacrosanct right because if you don't
place it above everything else
everything's more important than that
acutely right that you know you could go
to a movie you can pick up your dry
cleaning you could do whatever we have
to make these choices around ritual and
what we elevate
but one of the things I started to
notice is that's a space that I did a
lot of really deep meditation and
reflection around stuff and if I don't
if I fall out of that for two three days
all of a sudden other parts of my life
start to get disorganized and so after
Exodus I've started to view that time in
a very different light and started to
view and start my mornings even in
different ways and then as I've done
that there's been more
um
rituals
um I don't say demands but understanding
of different ways to have threshold
moments of reorienting myself that feel
different from just like a cog B
right way of resetting like take five
breaths and then go into whatever it's
not about just the psychology the
nervous system it's really about taking
time to try and reintegrate and Orient
to the highest version of something and
to ask to ask for that it's very
interesting in orphanax when he answers
the phone he answers the phone the same
way every time he says do you need my
help
and I never thought about that right
he's an assassin who helps people who
are in in desperate need but of course
that's the first question because if
somebody doesn't ask for help they're
not in a position that you can help them
right I never thought of it that way but
in a way that reflection towards the
higher good is also an expression of
humility that you're open to what will
come like you're leaving space for other
Solutions and answers which means I
don't have them I don't have them to go
out into the Roar of a new day to
control and shape the day you know
another thing C.S Lewis talks about is
he says the greatest
trick that the enemy or that they can
foist on other people sorry to protect
them from the enemy and screw tape
letters of course the enemy's God right
and the father is Satan but he says is
the belief that their time is their own
if you can convince a man that his time
is his own
everything's an imposition everything's
cause for aggravation yeah right
anything that comes off their schedule
any aggravation anything like if you can
convince him of that like your gold
that's a key thing and so there's so
many Reflections like that and for me a
lot of what was been really meaningful
in C.S Lewis is
you know clearly he's a spirit he's
intellectual spiritual genius right it's
uh
but
the acuteness of psychology is so
amazing to me and so I think a lot of
the way that that I came to into
understandings of sort of archetypes and
spirituality and the way that actually
they move in the world in concrete ways
and move the world and move you for me
was through young right which which
makes sense it's coming from my
background right so I studied young a
great deal right and did a lot of work
on Young and you get to the bottom and
you start to realize oh this there's
this amazing overlap like with my
friends who were born again Christian
where all of a sudden it's like oh if I
convert some of these phrases and engage
with this in this way I understand
people who are speaking Jesus right
because it's it's a way in to start to
understand and go oh when you say you
know it's you know leave room for God
that's like jungian synchronicity right
there's all these terms that are just
different slices and ways into it
um or into reaching a deeper reservoir
of understanding
um and so C.S Lewis that his like the
acuteness of insight he's so
perspicacious about like how our mind
how our minds work and the connection of
those to a spiritual frame for me was
was pretty spectacular yeah and it's
like a great divorce right you I read
the great divorce and that was like
here's what you thought about the great
divorce because it
that's one of my favorite CS Lewis books
I think it's one of the best uh
representation of
heaven and hell like the the idea of
heaven and hell that uh that has ever
been put together so I don't know what
you thought about that oh and how like
all the ways he just lays bare that we
get in the way of our own of the gifts
being offered
yeah exactly every which way it's like
here's here's every way that you could
show up and be offered everything you
want and deny it due to your own
you know blindness or your your lack of
cultivated humility yeah yeah it was
amazing right and so you always think
about that woman who'd rather have her
boy in hell with her so she could
continue to provide endless care and
empathy and right like devouring mother
witch and Hansel and gretleness right
but she'd rather have that child
devoured and taken down than to open and
release you know there's different value
sets Old Testament New Testament in a
lot of ways I mean the the Old Testament
there's this like talmudic reasoning
right and there's so much about work and
discipline and law and code and I think
a lot of the virtues of the New
Testament are around like surrender
right like there's I mean they're
they're through both of them of course
this is an oversimplification uh you
know forgiveness Grace there's so much
it's such a different
um value set and so watching this bus
ride
you know up to heaven in person after
person I mean the other thing that was
really interesting to me is there's
someone who came who is uh in the great
divorce who's a you know great expert in
religion I forget what they're wrong
yeah that's awesome that's a great scene
yeah
yeah the Theologian who like couldn't
join heaven or or stay because you know
he needs to be able to have arguments
and differences and there it has to be
cerebral and he has to retain his own
like you know sense of intellectual
curiosity and disagreement and like you
know I never would yield and how much
were lost in our prefrontal cortexes all
the time
um yeah so he's he's amazing I mean it
was that's been a pretty spectacular
process and I think about that a lot in
relation to people who we see who were
and in ourselves primarily in ourselves
first all the ways we self-handicap
right all the ways we create obstacles
based on our own
ego or vanity right or Pride
um and you see it reflected in those
ways but it also gives room for
um allowing more space and freedom for
others to sort of have to flower in
their own time right because you can't I
mean that's another aspect of freedom is
anything that's that's coerced this is
back to the discussion about the sort of
uh Global or let's just say outsourced
to like the insane Roar of the internet
Bob mentality to dictate like our moral
governance which is it's so insane it's
almost hard to figure out that we're in
America in Canada
in these in these countries that are
that where free speech is foundational
that we've allowed a state of affairs
that random mobs online on social media
apps can be for blood and we have no
idea who they are how they're
constituted how much foreign negative
influences in them how many Psychopaths
what the Constitution is and public
figures will come out like to a town
square and apologize in a way that often
is disingenuous just to be left alone to
be allowed to continue their lives
without massive financial and
reputational damage like we've allowed
that to happen someone's not been
convicted of a crime someone hasn't been
fired from a job but just a random mob
can constitute itself and make that
demand
it's insane it is insane and it feels
like
yeah it reminds you of what is real like
and what is not real the online world is
really in some ways like the chattering
of demons like because it's a people
let's say tanak and the people who these
an anonymous troll type people you know
you also know that the not all of them
but a lot of people that's not their
whole personality anyways it's almost
like I'm gonna go online and I can play
this like role uh you know and then they
go back and they they like live their
life almost like a little like a little
it's a video game it's a first person
shooter video game right I'm going
online I'm gonna own the labs I'm going
online I'm gonna dismantle Mega people
yeah and that's my way I'm virtuous I'm
playing a game and I'm virtualized while
I'm doing it but it's crazy that that
level of like really like we had a
pretty good common law system we have
pretty good courts we did this is what
we're gonna decide to do that anyone at
any time or any member of One group
can make a claim of being offended by
any member of another group and if they
get enough pitchforks and torches that
other group has to answer to them yeah
it's it's it's really crazy if you think
about it if we transport ourselves
forward from the 80s and said this is
what it is now it doesn't matter if
you're a movie star or Senator or CEO an
athlete uh uh you know an iron worker a
coal miner a musician anything you do at
any time a random mob can appear and
then just in a virtual world and make
you have to come you you either have be
in the fight of your life to stand up
for your principles or like falsely
apologize like you're being marched
through the streets in Game of Thrones
that's wild yeah and I mean obviously
that's that's in some part what's going
on with Jordan right now but I I just
want to come back to the the CS Lewis
thing just because when we saw each
other last time you reminded me of a
scene in portrait of the Artist as a
Young Man by James Joy and I'd read that
into my early early 20s and I had
forgotten about some of the parts I
reread it uh and in that book there's a
description of Hell which goes on for
quite a long time and it's interesting
because that description of hell is this
like really punitive thing right it's
like it's like horrible punitive thing
uh that's gonna last forever and it's
like you know imagine a bird taking a
seed of a mountain of seeds for you know
it's like it's it's like that's just one
second in eternity and and it and what I
what I just found fascinating was
because I also re-read the great divorce
I knew you had read it you had read it
so I'm like I read that a few times in
my life uh and I thought just how
powerful the difference is between the
Visions like on the one hand Joyce you
know and you can understand when
somebody led him away from the church if
he really experienced something like
that where it's just this this this all
arbitrary almost in a horrible uh
imposition of uh of a standard that you
can't follow until you end up in this
this tortured forever whereas C.S Lewis
has this amazing capacity to show how
the suffering of hell like the suffering
of hell is out of your own desire that
it actually is born out of something you
want for yourself ultimately without
maybe admitting it to yourself but that
you you want that that image that he has
of Hell of people who have everything
they want
so because they have everything they
want they they get annoyed at
everybody's little differences so they
said they keep moving away from the
neighborhood and building houses further
and further away from each other and so
all of a sudden they're like alone in
these giant mansions but they're so
they're like a million miles from each
other and they can't even fathom to be
with another person I'm like wow that's
a powerful image of of suffering but
born out of our own desires
it's amazing it's also and I say this
with great love for Catholics and the
Jesuits who partially raised me I mean
some ways it's like a Catholic Christian
division there in some ways and Joyce
has like the most Hellfire and brimstone
of anything so that I think it's the
third chapter a portrait of the artist
is just it's worth just going into
because it's so kind of gloriously
hideous so first he goes through every
single one of our senses and talks about
how awful it is in hell like your ears
hear the screams and your skin is on
fire so as they're teaching him you know
when he's young in his his Catholic
school or he's in in church you're
taught all of the ways that your senses
are in a state of unbelievable
inquisitional
horror right and pain and excruciating
but then he says like you said imagine
there's a mountain that's a million
miles high and a million miles wide
and every million years a bird flies and
picks up one grain of sand and flies a
million miles and drops it somewhere
else when those mountains have risen and
Fallen a million times that's not even
an instant in hell yeah you know like oh
and so you can see why one of the things
Joy said was to be an artist he had to
be free from family country and religion
those were the three Nets that were
thrown to constrain an artist
right and he had to be free of them to
be his own
sort of um brilliant embodied creative
self yeah and C.S Lewis did so much
Kinder I mean it's you know hell is
locked from the inside and you have the
key yeah and it's just right there and
the the notion of God is is it's so much
more patient and graceful it's sort of
like Hey we're here you can take the bus
back next year if you want it's all
right here but you know if you want to
still maintain your own theological
distinctions and that's important to you
it's okay you can go back to your house
that's you know in this gray Town that's
you know a thousand miles from the
nearest home where you're separated from
an overarching narrative and from each
other which by the way I think is is
where ai's heading we've talked about
this right like oh I can get my own I
can push a button and it's on my own
book like I want a Faulkner book that's
dialed to my IQ that's 107 with vocab
words the tap the link using inside
jokes from my social media boom I have
what I want it's like pornography right
or boys I have everything that I want
what's what are all my tastes and
preferences and all of a sudden you're
just floating away in your own little
bubble of a world you know like you know
when they die from the feast with the
meat of the last like gorging still
stuck in their kids
yeah that's right I have everything I
want and it's like online I can do that
I can cultivate my own world I can move
people I can unfriend people I don't
like I can put filters on everything
it's like wow so what you're doing is is
you're removed from an overarching story
and from everybody else in reality like
why does that sound familiar yeah and so
the but the but the depiction of the
great divorce is amazing you know so one
of the other things I've been thinking
about a lot since Exodus is this notion
like one of the biggest
the biggest Fury in a lot of ways that I
see of our stalemate in politics there's
two things I want to talk to you about
the biggest one I see is hypocrisy right
so you know and it's it's abundant on
both sides we don't even get into
specific examples because like then the
comments just blow up and there's a
thousand things but people are outraged
with the hypocrisy of of why is this
prosecuted this way and not this way why
are you saying it's state rights but
it's not state rights here
and the church you know one of the
things that's the most typical thing to
be said in a secular
uh
World these words are so useless but you
know we're using these as imperfect
proxies for what we're talking about is
the hypocrisy of the church is the
hypocrisy of church leaders right
there's ways that like shockingly the
churches haven't
you know as all the institutions have
allowed in corruption and capture right
Academia and the media and Hollywood
some of that's also true in in in
religious institutions also that that
has been allowed but it's this very
interesting thing where there's this
notion of like well you say you're a
Christian
but you had an affair or you say you're
a Christian but you stole money or you
say you're a Christian but you didn't
show Grace and humility of Christ you
know or whatever and it's so interesting
to me like you know having
lifelong close friends I mean it's such
an it's such an amusing and callow
disregard of it it's like okay because I
say that I'm orienting myself towards a
certain belief structure I'm supposed to
exemplify the highest Exemplar of that
in the history of the world all the time
where I'm a hypocrite yeah it's like
that's the way that I'm aiming as an
individual if you're a Christian it's
like of course you're gonna people in
that Community are gonna Gamble and have
affairs and do all this stuff that's
like saying oh you secularist you have
all these laws but people are still
committing murder and people are still
stealing things like what Hypocrites you
are to think that you have a legal
system you want to pay attention to when
people don't abide at yeah and so this
this is the sort of plank in the eye
approach of like we're so
scrambling between these worlds of the
of the religious spiritual symbolic and
the secular you know aridly intellectual
to to cast these aspersions uh on the
other side but but you know the one
thing I think that I will say is a base
setting
that I have found increasingly useful
since
my I had some pretty deep forays into
the political space in hopes of doing
some good and moving parties towards
moderation and discussion and
negotiation right like I think in a lot
of ways
I like I I hope to be a sort of bridge
builder because as a novelist I
the primary thing that I like to do is
to really embody other people and
perspectives
um but you know that that sort of anger
at the lack of embodied Perfection one
of the things that I find really uh
wonderful in my friends and Community
who are more spiritual religious or have
a belief structure as part of that
structure is we're all flawed we're all
flawed we all have a long way to go
right and
without that recognition there's not a
lot to go you know if you have a view
where you're like look I figured it out
here's my politics you know from either
side here's my politics here's my
structure here's my community here's my
values here's all the ways that I
fulfill those I have codes in my life
and I fulfill them perfectly it's like
oh I don't know how to talk to you like
if you really think that like you're
just not looking you're just not pulling
the curtain back on your mind that's
right there's so many ways to do
everything better all the time and in
some ways it has to do with this
question of idolatry that's interesting
to think about that way because
what the surprise that we find is that
you know if we remove that absolute
Transcendence like if we just like no we
don't need this we just have the state
we just have the we just have the the
social sphere then what will happen is
exactly what you said which is that
we'll treat we'll do it unconsciously it
will treat others as if they should be
God
and therefore as soon as we find one
little fault in someone then we will
want to tear them down and Destroy them
if you look at the way that the
medievals for example saw so like
history uh there was a tradition that's
called the nine worthies and the the
nine were these were were nine uh social
leaders three Jews three like uh old
school like Hellenistic uh or Romans and
then three Christians and with the way
they would do it is like Julius Caesar
right they say Julius Caesar was a great
man here's the reasons why we admire him
and hear all the horrible things that he
did
and there's Alexander Alexander was what
was great here is how Alexander was
great and with the great things he did
and here are his sins here are the
things that he lacked and there was a
sense in which they knew they of course
these people had faults right of course
they had just like Moses in this in the
in the scripture hits the Rock and Aaron
builds the golden calf and you know King
David has an affair and like we know
that humans are
are are weak and and so there's a sense
in which we can still say David was a
great king but and know that he did
these horrible things yeah
so in a way
it calls to mind two things I mean one
of them is the Vatican has The Devil's
Advocate as a formal position right
Christopher Hitchens who I miss more
than maybe anybody just to know what he
would say In This Moment he was so
singular right I mean I would love to
hear what Christopher Hitchens would say
about everything but he tells the story
that he was a big critic of mother
Terese in a bunch of ways and he
describes the interview so they got him
on like news I forget what MSNBC or fox
or something as her caskets being born
lovingly through like the slums of
Calcutta and he said here he is with the
ill-advised goatee like saying why she
was not worthy but the Vatican actually
contacted him to be the Devil's Advocate
to make the case against her
yeah there's a formal position to do
that but so we take what you're saying
right now
about this about did we find one little
flaw and then we we move into a world
where literally we have given up by
ourselves
all of our not all of many of us have
intensely given up a ton of our freedom
and a ton of our privacy and so I had a
friend yesterday was talking about a
lawsuit and they contacted somebody and
they're going to subpoena the tax so my
phone's like how can they subpoena the
texts and it's like do you ever read
the 60 page things that are the contract
agreements let alone parse it through a
team of lawyers you don't own that we
don't own anything we've taken this and
gone let me give everything away and by
the way also I'm going to go on social
media and post names and make jokes and
come from one small culture or community
and make a joke in another that's
happened you know one of our our dear
friends has been caught out of that a
number of times colliding with my
various timelines
and basically what we're discovering is
is that nobody nobody on the planet is
perfect and so if you want to put a
Target on Tim Scott or Nikki Haley or
Nancy Pelosi or Ozzy Osbourne or
you know Oliver Anthony who's the guy
who just sung that Anthem or you or me
it's there you can interpret anybody
through a frame and find something
that's offensive online probably because
it's impossible with the it's impossible
to maintain the image like FDR when he
was president you know suffering from he
had um polio as a kid
as and was in a wheelchair and no one
ever knew the Press like very
respectfully never shot him in his
wheelchair they'd shoot him by the desk
they'd shoot him standing we don't have
any of that anymore so it's like you
think you're gonna pry into any human
and so this game were like hyenas right
like something gets turned up somebody
reaches a certain level of ascendancy in
the culture JK Rowling where do we find
something anything even if it makes no
sense and Ripper to shreds yeah it's
it's just it's just horrible and you
know in a way I think
part of the solution is
a recognition instead of an apology when
being caught out to go
this is this is where I am this is who I
am I'm not going to purport to be
perfect under every which way it's it's
not having a react but we've turned
people who want to engage on a more
um on a wider stage like the amount of
hatred even you and I which is a much
lesser level than if we talk about you
know Jordan or if we talk about you know
other people in our orbit on both sides
of the fats you know Dean Phillips is a
is a close friend of mine who's a
congressman who just made some
statements that we might want some more
diversity in the presidential race
behind besides baidab you know when
people are at a high level the amount of
just like vitriol that's directed at
them is incredible right and then people
get bellicose and reaction it's this
horrible blood sport that we've kind of
allowed and entertained
yeah and it's weird people forget like I
and you see it even from the Christian
Perspective it's like forget the words
of Christ you know that to say judge not
lest you be judged and it's not and and
I really do believe though that that
that statement doesn't mean that you
should never judge anything anybody does
but it's rather to always keep that eye
inside first like always make sure that
that you are aware that you're a
hypocrite that you have fault that you
you know and and keep that as the as a
as a bear something that balances out
how you pour out your criticism towards
the outside world because like you said
one of the problems with criticizing the
outside world constantly is that it
makes us feel virtuous and it's almost
like it can be a little addiction right
it's like it because it gives you a
little kick of a virtue to to spew out
everything that's wrong about everybody
uh and everything all the time and
ultimately our eyes should be on
ourselves first that's for sure
that's right that's right and that that
discussion I was talking about with oz
of kind of like
lifting and lowering my gaze
simultaneously right away from sort of a
A globalist or a formed out a
centralized morality was the part where
I was like oh right I see this
differently in a certain way
but it's also you know careful what we
ask of people you know you want someone
who's a genius a big out of the box
thinker who like moves fast and has
thoughts and shatters things and moves
the world forward lurchingly like a
Galileo or you know the accidents and
mishaps that lead to Solutions like how
penicillin was discovered you know
Picasso uh Beethoven Mozart you know
Byron Keith Shelley like these people
who were just touched with fire were
brilliant
to start to judge and constrict all the
sides of it it's like no we just want
all the genius we just want all the
Brilliance we don't want the messiness
of it we don't want the messiness of it
and we don't want we want to make sure
that everything's aligned and
articulated perfectly and so I thought
about this a lot since our our
conversation that we have with Jordan
for instance you know one of the things
that really struck me and you and I
laughed about this afterwards was you
know we're there we were sort of
discussing with Jordan how to Tamp down
some of the stuff on Twitter which I
still think he should do in a way but
he's also you know
it's look he's figuring that out and
he's figuring out a lot of things yeah
but you know part of what we were
talking about was like look like have a
more tempered or a wider View and one of
the things that really struck me was and
Jordan's talked to me about saying look
when you get up for a fight with half
the world like you get up ahead of steam
you know if you know you're gonna speak
some truth that people are gonna crash
in and when you get up ahead of steam
there's swap there's mess there's force
and one of the things I thought that was
so funny is we got to the end of that
interview
and I thought I'd comported myself
pretty well and went back and watched it
and I was like
I was way too like coming in hot on
stuff and I needed an edit like
literally to take down some of the ways
that I was you know like Jordan would
see the point and I'd like hit him again
with it like in some ways I was like
wait I need I need some Grace shown to
me for how I'm you know coming into a
conversation about having more of a
steady uh even Cadence and discussing
issues as I'm giving that advice right
to somebody else doing it and it was
kind of it was a great thing to go
through because you know that was a
um stressful set of circumstances for me
just coming in to do that not bad
stressful you know but it challenging
challenging is a better word like
there's a lot of people who could be
upset with me from basically every angle
with that yeah and so to notice and see
yeah well when that happens people feel
that way all the time sometimes right
and I think that in your case it was a
tribute to you as well that you were
able to see that in yourself too to see
like oh wait a minute it's like oh I
also need to take my own advice in this
case to some extent like in this context
uh and I could be reliant on the grace
of others yes because it was like hey I
don't want to be you know look Jordan I
go Jordan and I can have a bare knuckle
discussion that's super loving and great
like as you've seen many times but when
it's in front of of something that's
like that it's like it's it's really
difficult I've been thinking a lot about
this you know my participation in Exodus
had different ramifications in certain
communities that I'm a part of like some
people were you know very upset with me
for staring sharing a stage with certain
people who are there or upset that I'd
participate or you know didn't
understand what I came back and was
talking about things in ways that they
didn't that weren't usual to them and
some people just recoiled like I have
some people I haven't
talked to since almost and I was put in
mind of
a couple things first reaction I felt
more I felt grievancy more immediately
this is kind of an interesting thing
that happened since we're talking about
Exodus but first I was like oh you just
want all my input and insight about how
to talk to and engage with the other
side and all the persuasion stuff from
my deep Dives in with with these bigger
personalities and brains that I do with
um you know respect and trying to learn
without any slop that's what you want
you want me to come to you and say hey
here's a whole framework of how to talk
to people without my brain Ever Getting
stretched or stretched out of shape or
my language being imperfect or the mess
of my processing and Swinging here and
coming back to here and refiguring and
it's like I don't know how to do that
like I can't I'm not going to come and
give you a spit out set of widgets about
how we start to engage with different
people without there being
like room for problems and some people
just simply don't want that here's the
precepts here's the ideology here's the
ways you need to speak here's the
language that's acceptable if you're
confusing anyway there you've been
infected and captured like you went on
and you're not who you are and I don't
trust you and your excise it's kind of
wild like what the range is that people
are demanding of something and I started
to think about that a lot with people
like you know it's not like
um
Elon Musk or Joe Rogan for instance are
like far-right conservative characters
by any stretch of the imagination but if
if they're if they're doing this these
sort of bigger Ventures and roaring
around and and and and and smashing
their way to truth in ways that are
imperfect and trying to accomplish
things and making mistakes if if part of
the predominant culture is oh you can't
say that you can't do that please don't
do this please just get us to the moon
and build tunnels but like don't do this
piece or don't do that piece of course
look it's a free marketplace right
everybody can have Corrections on people
no matter how powerful or brilliant and
we should but if it starts to become
that it every every bold Venture gets
you know
swarmed with mosquitoes and people are
you know are like blood sucked a
millimeter at a time and an endless
swarm you start to understand why people
start to disengage right from from
um
work that might be more obviously Unity
based and that's a lot of what we're
trying to do with Arc I think yeah is to
figure out how to have sets of values
and make sure that we're not
um
that were bearing them forward in ways
that are building bridges yeah it's
unbelievably hard to do yeah and you see
like I I obviously I've had that issue
with art myself where people I could I
mean some people criticizing me saying
well here's Jonathan you know he's going
to build the new WF he's participating
in this new globalist initiative he's
and and it's like okay
so
so so so so what so you're just allowed
to complain I guess right you're just
allowed to complain that you see these
great like globalist authoritarian
things coming towards you but if you in
any way tried to start a discussion with
people on how to find some alternative
or how to see differently than you're
then you're doing the same it's like
well I'm not like I can't imagine
I can't imagine just like bitching and
not not not trying to it's the same with
like the story the question right it's
like you know I've been watching people
that I that I respect you know and I've
been doing it myself for the past five
years complain about some of the story
tropes that are coming out of Apocalypse
right and I've been and I've been doing
it active I'm like this I think this is
not good this is leading us towards
towards towards kind of ideology and
it's bad storytelling and everything but
at some point I also have to tell if I'm
not going to start trying to tell better
stories then at some point I have to
shut up like I have to stop whining
because that's right then what are we
doing you know that's right well there's
another line in screw tape letters uh
versus CS Lewis is talking about like a
man in the house with his with his mom
he's living with his mother and saying
you know start to be annoyed with every
way she says stuff right or like her
tone or how she does this little thing
like if you can get somebody in a state
of mind right because we're we're
working for our father now who's the
devil if you can get somebody where
they're annoyed by every little thing
that somebody does well assuming that
none of that's true for you and that
every tone they have with hidden meaning
you can be offended by but all of your
hidden meanings and energy is them being
crazy and he says something like we want
them forever concerned with the state of
her soul but never her like rheumatoid
arthritis right like if we can remove
people to just only be outraged by the
abstract right then you can constantly
be annoyed in the details and in reality
and you have your perfect moral equation
is is in place and so I've been thinking
about that a lot
also with Arc but also this insane
notion that like
who you sit down with and learn from and
discuss and what you participate in
means that you're fully endorsing
everything that could come of it like
what a weird notion that I would want to
go to this Exodus seminar and sit down
with Dennis Prager and Ben Shapiro and
in doing so that I agree with every
single thing that they think and every
post that they've made an argument
they've made and them with me that
somehow association means not that
you're learning right I could take
there's a couple things that Ben said
that were you know enormously
eye-opening for me that's true
irrelevant if he tweets a bunch of stuff
that I don't agree with for reasons I
mean same as with Jordan there's a
totality of a human being and all the
things that they do and the engagement
and the dance without and ideas like
what an utterly bizarre notion that we
should be that that represents um
platforming them or contributing to
their wealth or stature it's so bizarre
it's like oh yeah well we could D we
de-platform Donald Trump all the way to
the most powerful human being on the
planet like how did that work out this
de-platforming notion let's D platform
Joe Rogan it's like Joe Rogan doesn't
need that there's if there is engagement
and you know for me a lot of the work
that I do there's these sort of
quotations from Desmond Tutu that that
bookend a lot of my thinking he always
says if you want peace you don't talk to
your friends you talk to your enemies
and another thing he said is an enemy is
a friend waiting to be made
and this notion that more separate is
good
um less tendrils if somebody's infected
corrupt captured judged in any way
several all 10 sever all ten rules of
connection from them send several all
bridges and attack them in full it's
like what are they going to do they're
gonna move and distant and fortify and
come back oh well they're doing that
anyways I hear this I hear the exact
same mirror argument both directions I
could have a conversation with
conservative friends and the claims I
can pick them right up and put them down
when I'm talking to more liberal friends
over here it's the exact same argument
the hypocrisy divorce from reality only
believing your own experts
um mind control
um and it's it's like there's these
these parallel structures of discussion
and the arguments followed the exact
same course there's like eight steps of
them that you can walk through
um yeah but that that that's so I mean I
don't understand I mean I I've always
struggled too to understand I I don't
know like I struggle to get into
psychology of someone who like let's say
post a picture of a good example in my
like from the more right-leaning type
people is like they'll post a picture of
some with Epstein and they'll say like
this and they'll say like that's it it's
like this person now is like basically
non-human because there's this picture
that exists of them with someone who's a
horrible human it's like that's crazy
like that's a frightening thing because
can you imagine really seriously
thinking that that just because you met
someone in some conference or in some
context and there's a picture that's
taken of you that all of a sudden we
could compromise you forever because of
because of that that's a that's wild
well as a novelist it's like I've
interviewed Outlaw Bikers I've
interviewed murderers I mean I've
interviewed like you know Heist guys
it's that's all fine I can go conduct
any interview to understand to to focus
to do deep Dives on people terrorists
that's all acceptable but if somebody
has a different location
right it's done and the thing that's
also so weird is like let's say even
that one of these people is is proves to
be uniformly evil like that that's also
like an assumption you make when you
cancel somebody they're so irredeemable
it's also such an amazing notion that
it's not that everybody's where they are
on their own journey of life and that
there's always hope for
um Grace or learning or movement it's
like no it's it's done it's locked right
now like they're permanently awful and
so you think okay let's say that's true
even let's say that we take that leap
that that philosophical leap don't you
want to engage with them to comprehend
how they think and where the
vulnerabilities are and where the weak
spots are and where the points are for
even joining or contending are there any
ways you can align your resources are
there any ways you can understand the
Playbook better are there ways that you
want to deal with and wrestle with an
adversary like just in a straight Sun
Tzu know that like even even seeing them
as an adversary you should want to
engage with them to some extent because
then right you don't know your enemy
then you'll be taken out without without
you know you'll be taken out and you
won't know why because you haven't let
let alone if they're people with you
know giant you know sets of I mean you
know spheres of influence and
relationships I always think of it as
like if you're conducting a battle
between good and evil you know it's like
oh well this person over here who you've
decided is canceled has like a battalion
of Tanks right but oh they're bad we
just let's talk to them we're not going
to talk yeah we don't we don't want
those tanks let's insult those tanks
till they come for us it's like what are
you talking about right like this is
this is it's it's time I I feel like
it's time that we have to you and I've
talked about
um pluralistic ignorance right it's in
Cults it's one of the ways that Cults
operate I mean there's a bunch of ways
Cults operate like our current culture
is operating you know one of them is is
they want to cut off access to outside
information
they divide people from your family and
they do it in a way that's flattering
because they're like oh you're so
amazing yeah your family's always just
wanted to hold you back like you're
finally you're full of self who we see
so you several people right all the and
we think about all these people I
haven't talked to my My Crazy Sisters of
you know uh uh liberal Lefty who's lost
my uncle's a bag of guy you sever
everybody so that you can't see the
humanity in them so that's number one
access you know limit outside
information then there's privacy
deprivation if you're up at a cult
setting let's say you have a part you go
someone goes with you to the bathroom
someone's with you first when you wake
up in the morning when you go about at
night and everywhere you go they're
they're dealing with Jonathan cult
Jonathan not Jonathan Jonathan yeah then
so privacy deprivation is this now
there's nowhere we go that this can't
come and reach is it dinner time in most
households doesn't matter are you in
class does it matter are you at home in
your dorm room at the end of the day
you're at the end of a work day doesn't
matter it's with us everywhere and the
other is pluralistic ignorance that
everybody is sort of individually
miserable or unfulfilled or far from a
truth they want to speak but they can't
share it because everywhere they look
there's these teams of hyenas waiting to
just descend on them and tear them to
shreds so you're not safe to speak out
and that's social I went undercover and
occult man I went to a thing outside LAX
I was researching a book I read a book
that took place in in mind control
quotes I was in a horseshoe big like
Ballroom where they have weddings in one
of those big airport hotels 250 people
and they shape it like a horseshoe so
you can see everybody and when they say
everyone ready for growth stand up
and you sit
and 249 people are standing and they all
look at you that's powerful yeah it's
powerful Colts want people who are
healthy who were responsive to healthy
reactions like social embarrassment
right they don't want someone who's a
delusional schizophrenic they don't care
so these pressures that are happening
where people are like I don't know like
I I believe in uh you know that people
are allowed dignity and private choices
and rights but I don't quite want to
celebrate everything around that all the
time but if I say that I'll get killed
let me just be quiet if 80 of people
think that but they're frozen in a state
where they can't communicate as that's
pluralistic ignorance yeah and so much
of what I increasingly see as
the task that I want to help or the way
that I want to help is to try to shatter
that through conversations rather than
well if we elect this group of people
here and this group of people there and
they do these things and pass this
legislation then we'll be good it's like
it's about foundationally rebuilding
like
like we discussed for 32 hours in Exodus
how are we going to re how are we going
to orient a space in a world in which
the center holds right and The Fringe
holds and has its place and that place
will flourish and feed the center and
the center can hold and protect
um and provide structure and I think a
lot of that is having the kinds of
conversations people don't want there's
so many truths that that are just so
foundational that people just won't
speak that are just obvious Beyond
Compare yeah yeah
listen Greg I think I think we should
end it there that was a that was a great
that was a great finish
and so I I appreciate your time and I'm
looking forward to seeing you at ARC and
then uh possibly at another
discussion possible we'll see we will
see it's still it's still being
discussed but that is something that
might happen so that would be great yeah
it's always fun talking to you man it's
good to see you